hey how's Gomez's today we have another
challenge video for you Prez I got
beaten by noodles that's not what it's
called but anyway it's jelly beans that
are either yummy flavor or discussing
flavor so we have either tutti frutti or
stinky socks either popcorn or rotten
egg either peach or vomit juicy pear or
booger lime or lawn clippings berry blue
or toothpaste chocolate pudding or dog
food they both sound disgusting coconut
or baby wipes
anytime I die I will have to eat one and
it would either be yummy
or it will be disgusting I ask you
brothers for which game to play it with
this and you bros always suggests the
highest quality of games of course you
never failed me so we're playing
bicicleta Pokemon also known as Pokemon
bike oh god the graphics look at that /
- man look at that [ __ ] Pikachu look
at my lips ah this is the greatest game
of all time Thank You breads for
suggesting it ah oh my god what just a
bad joke oh god oh god all right here
comes I could either get booger flavor
or juicy ain't it
Oh got lime mmm best game ever thanks
for us Wow
let's go Pikachu you little [ __ ]
oh my god aah back up back okay so this
is toothpaste or berry blue that's to
face but it's it's good I like it
Pikachu he got you now damn I ate two
things you go ah this gave me the body
buff Oh what are you trying to don't
lick my Pikachu coughing lawn clippings
or lime
[Music]
that is lawn clippings it's like eating
grass oh my god
ha ha come pick it joke I don't want to
eat your [ __ ] pick it you back Joe
alright another one please no rotten egg
oh god no it's it's white the baby wipes
or coconut
[Music]
Oh
oh oh oh hello oh oh oh oh I'm sorry
[ __ ] you're from the love of god I hate
me hey I think I got the hang of it
Pikachu Allah no or baby wipes huh peach
or vomit peach peace ah
[Music]
ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah
Oh rotten egg or buttered popcorn
please be popcorn
[Music]
ah
all right Pikachu oh god your flight oh
you [ __ ] fly Big Chill a disgusting
thing out of my life [ __ ] hate you
Pikachu
you've ruined my life I hurt myself
today
[Music]
another blue hmm that's blueberry mmm
yummy
pick a [ __ ] for the [ __ ] shows boss
Pikachu show a mousse box Pikachu shots
make a joke very Chris that no one ever
was
see I'm never gonna die now oh I didn't
last long did it
booger or juicy Pierre
I cry okay I hope you enjoyed Pokemon
and Pikachu please leave a like for more
challenges and I will see you in the
next one
[Music]
hahahahahahaha